pero no quiero proponer aquí tenemos
ocho fichas y aquí tenemos una moneda
normal revisa la ciencia se ve normal no
tiene nada raro muy bien vamos a echar
volados qué prefieres águila rápida ya
de por sí en el primero que gane tres
volados se lleva el bonche de las ocho
fichas de acuerdo entonces el primero
que llegue a tres es decir si saco tres
águilas antes de que salgan tres soles
yo me llevo todo y si salen tres soles
antes de que salgan tres águilas tú te
llevas todo correcto exactamente te
parece bien incluso si aportamos me
parece muy bien aquí tenemos águilas y
aquí tenemos sol es perfecto muy bien
para el primer volador
soy
de acuerdo
águila y la vamos bien vamos bien
voy cantando
me voy a tener que ir pero es que estoy
a punto de ganar si yo sé perdón te
parece bien si dividimos a la mitad las
fichas no es que si en el próximo volado
sale aguilar me llevo todas yo sé pero
mira yo también gane uno podría ganar
los dos siguientes y llevar aumento del
ponche
estoy de acuerdo sí pero yo tengo más
posibilidad de ganar que tú